Hold on, before we begin this video, there’s
something really important we need you to do. Just
remember this phrase, while you’re watching it’s
critical that you don’t let these four words slip
out of your head, even for a split second. You can
even pause the video and repeat the sentence to
yourself a few times, just to get it to fully
sink in. Remember, please: Belief is the key.
We have all wondered at one point or another,
“what happens after?” After our lives draw to
their inevitable close, and we take our
last breath in the land of the living,
what happens to us? It’s a question that has
baffled scientists and philosophers all over the
world for almost as long as human civilization
has existed: What happens after we die? Well,
the answer to that particular question normally
varies depending on who you choose to ask.
There are, as you probably already know, numerous
beliefs held by all religions and cultures around
the globe, that there exists an afterlife.
While the description of the afterlife is often
dependent on the religious or cultural group it
is linked to, the concept usually revolves around
the soul leaving the body after death, and living
forever in eternal paradise. That is, of course,
unless you’ve committed sin during your lifetime,
which normally results in being sent down to spend
eternity in punishment instead of paradise.
But sadly, there’s no way to prove which, if
any of the various afterlives, actually exist. By
their very nature, these afterlives exist separate
from the real, physical world that we live in
while we are still alive. Stuck here on Earth,
we can only observe what we see happening after
death, and what we assume it might be like.
After all, it’s not like a dead person
can tell us what being dead is like…
well, under usual circumstances anyway.
With no proof of the afterlife’s existence,
we do unfortunately get left with the bleak
and existentially horrifying assumption that,
when we die, there is nothing waiting for us on
the other side, no light at the end of the tunnel,
no pearly gates, just… nothing, forever. Of
course, being unconscious for eternity isn’t
quite as bad as the other possibility.
What could that other possibility be?
Well, according to the SCP Foundation’s entry
for SCP-2718, you might not want to know. Anyone
attempting to access the data file on SCP-2718
will immediately notice a few details that set
it apart from others contained in the Foundation’s
archive. Firstly, an ever-changing SCP number - It
perpetually swaps numbers with other files to keep
itself hidden. Next, a unique object class that is
only found in this entry. Instead of the Keter
or Euclid or Safe class that you might expect,
you’ll read ‘dammerung’, a German word
that loosely translates to either dusk,
dawn, twilight, or nightfall.
You might also spot the anomaly’s
special containment procedures, mentioning
that this page of the SCP database has been
specially constructed in such a way that
makes it as difficult as possible to access.
The entry itself even begs the person
reading it not to go any further,
not to look at the description of SCP-2718.
Now, we all know that the Foundation goes to
great lengths to keep some things a secret,
but why all the added measures for SCP-2718?
It might well be that the information contained
behind all this extra security could change the
lives of anyone that reads it. Or, to put it
more accurately, it could change the afterlives
of whoever learns what SCP-2718 really is.
This anomaly isn’t a nightmarish creature or
an object with a strange function, it’s not
an entity from outside our universe or even
a person with an unusual origin. SCP-2718 is a
cognitohazard, a piece of information that poses a
direct danger to anyone that is able to understand
it. That’s why the Foundation has so many pleas
to not read any further, they’re not doing that
to protect the organization and their secrets,
but to try and protect the reader themselves.
“All personnel, regardless of clearance,
are forbidden to expose themselves to
the Description of this article under
any circumstances… Do not discuss the existence
of this article with any person. No disciplinary
action will be necessary, provided you close
this article now, and clear your browser cache.”
Sounds serious, right? So serious, in fact, that
anyone trying to learn about SCP-2718 is actively
discouraged to do so, even members of Foundation
personnel are offered exemption from punishment
if they just do what they’re told, and turn away.
But you still want to know, don’t you?
Alright, don’t say we didn’t try our best
to warn you. You’ve ignored all the signs,
the repeated warnings to not look any further into
SCP-2718, to not look at its description or pass
that information on to anyone else. No, you just
had to keep digging deeper and deeper, didn’t you?
Searching for the answers you’re going to wish
you had never gone looking for in the first place.
Push far enough through the security measures the
Foundation have placed around the SCP-2718 file,
and you’ll find a transcribed audio recording
from none other than a member of the O5 Council.
The councilwoman Miriam Prayther, O5-7, speaks
to a subordinate who begins the recording. As it
starts, she talks about how the various members of
the O5 Council have used various anomalous means,
and sometimes other SCPs, to artificially extend
their lifespans. The council is functionally
immortal. Boring, right? Anyone who knows enough
about the SCP Foundation already knows that
functional immortality is what has kept the O5s in
power for so many decades. But what you might not
know, is there was one council member who didn’t.
His name was Roger Sheldon. Despite being offered
each of the nineteen known methods of extending
life that the other overseers had gladly used,
Sheldon refused each and every one. Instead,
he would often go on vacations away from the
Foundation, without announcing his intention to
do so. Both doing this and refusing to become
immortal in some way are actions that are now
forbidden for any member of the O5 Council,
presumably because of Roger.
On one of his impromptu trips away,
Roger Sheldon died from a stroke. Given that he
didn’t let anyone know where he was planning on
going, he was sadly left to rot after his death.
However, Roger possessed an important anomalous
artifact in his possession at all times, meaning
that the SCP Foundation was keen to recover his
body and by extension, this object. He
also had knowledge of a unique keyword,
a phrase referred to as a shibboleth, which the
other overseers needed to extract from Sheldon.
But how do you get information from a dead man?
Well, you bring him back to life, of course.
And we’re not talking about the normal kind of
“resurrection” the Foundation often indulges in,
which is really just glorified cloning. This is
the ripping of an actual soul back from the void,
and placing it inside its body once more
so it can live again as it once did.
Eventually, after fourteen years of searching,
Roger Sheldon’s remains were exhumed and then
returned to the Foundation. There, his personal
belongings were recovered, including the
mysterious artifact. Then, just as planned, they
revived Roger in order to recover the shibboleth
from his memory. The O5 Council had commissioned
the creation of a brand new body for Roger,
one that perfectly matched his old one in every
conceivable detail. And it worked. What was odd
was that the formerly deceased overseer, who had
refused to extend his lifespan and live forever,
seemed overjoyed to be brought back from the dead.
The resurrection seemed to work exactly as
intended, even better in fact, with Roger now
firmly back among the living. He appeared to have
a newfound interest in preserving human life,
and empathy for others that he’d never shown
before. Sheldon was concerned about personnel
safety and containment protocols in a way he
hadn’t been before his stroke. But this apparent
compassion was underscored by something else:
caution. Roger never went anywhere without
an entourage of medical staff and bodyguards,
almost frightened of how fragile life was.
You might think there’s nothing too alarming
about that behavior, that maybe death had given
Sheldon a new perspective, an appreciation for
the delicate nature of human life. But it was
more than that, it was an unprecedented fear,
a phobia of allowing people, anyone, to die.
Then came Roger Sheldon’s most unpredictable
course of action. Acting against all regulations
and Foundation protocols, he secretly rushed into
the containment chamber of SCP-106. This anomaly
is a humanoid that secretes a black goop from its
body, capable of dragging human beings into a
pocket dimension that it controls and uses to
torture its victims. Sheldon was trying to make
some kind of bargain with SCP-106 when he was
detained by Miriam Prayther. When told to explain
his actions, Roger Sheldon eventually gave them
his horrifying testimony, the reason he’d been
so afraid and so cautious after his resurrection:
he knew what happened after death.
Cast your mind back to the start of
this video, all that talk about afterlives and
what really happens to us after we die. Well,
there is one answer to that question that
doesn’t often cross people’s minds. In fact,
everyone who ponders the question ‘what happens
after’ subconsciously tries to overlook it,
because to even think it’s possible
presents a whole horde of horrors in itself.
What could be such a terrifying thought, that we
all hope it simply isn’t true? It’s the simple,
horrible possibility that has hardly
occurred to anyone throughout human history:
that the dead remain conscious after their
bodies have shut down. They remain aware of
everything that happens to them, they are
able to feel themselves slowly decaying,
bones and skin withering away, buried under the
cold, wasting away into nothingness day after day.
That is what SCP-2718 is.
After suffering his stroke,
Roger Sheldon explained how he could
still feel everything happening to him.
“My skin blistered and split in the sunlight;
biting insects descended rapidly. I felt eggs
hatch, larvae crawl, gases build and burst
within me, individual cells rupturing,
interstitial fluids souring and blackening.
Somehow my capacity to experience and store these
sensations grew… I was aware of every fingernail
and strand of hair that pulled away in the wind…”
He went on, describing every horror he’d
experienced in lurid detail as his body
broke down in real-time, knowing that those same
images and thoughts would never leave his head.
Shocked by the revelation, Miriam and the
other Overseer rushed to hold a meeting of
the rest of the O5 Council, wherein Roger once
again described his posthumous experience.
Hearing what happens after death drove every
council member mad, each reacting with shock,
stress, and anger. One of them tried to calm the
rest down, while another motioned to treat death
itself as a Keter class SCP and neutralize it. The
chaos was eventually quelled when O5-1 silenced
the other O5s, activating Emergency Protocol 17
to gas the overseers with amnestics to wipe their
memories of what they had learned. Only Roger
and -7 were able to escape the room before the
bulkhead sealed and the gas was deployed.
Roger believed that people had a right to
know about SCP-2718. Agreeing with him, Miriam
created a log of all she knew about what happens
after death, then permanently locked it within the
SCP database, protected from ever being deleted
or having its description altered. However, on
the orders of O5-1, Miriam was gunned down by
Foundation personnel, leaving Roger to escape.
Presumably, he returned to SCP-106, agreeing
to be tortured forever in the creature’s pocket
dimension. To him, that was preferable to dying.
So, if you now know what SCP-2718 is, then why
did we start this video with the phrase ‘Belief is
the key’? Well, as we said earlier, this anomaly
is a cognitohazard, it’s a phenomenon that only
occurs after you are exposed to a certain piece
of information. That knowledge is what is being
contained here, within the entry left by O5-7.
You see, it’s actually knowing what happens to
you after death that makes SCP-2718 happen.
If you spend your life believing in a version
of the afterlife, only to then learn
about SCP-2718, then that information
will override whatever a religion, culture,
or faith led you to believe about death.
Knowing about SCP-2718 overwrites your afterlife.
It creates a new, endless and meaningless pain
as you experience every sensation beyond your
death. Decay, decomposition, cremation. That’s the
reason that belief is the key, because once you
are exposed to it, SCP-2718 becomes what happens
after you die. In our defense: We warned you...
Now go check out “SCP–2935 – O, Death” and
“SCP-657 - Death-predicting Man” for more
anomalies about Death: The true final frontier!